hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report we're in Paris you know so many
people reference the Marie Antoinette
quote let them eat cake and then you
know historians have gone back and they
said you know it's actually not cake
it's brioche it's brioche you know that
so I brought in actual oh my god what a
mess we brought in actual brioche this
is a brioche that's been sliced there at
the patisserie and so this is what she
suggested that the peasants that should
be eating because they had run out of
pen you say this is a brioche is a
slightly nicer version of path there's a
few in the cupboard let's throw that to
the peasants and maybe that'll shut them
up yes I believe there had been a wheat
disaster because of the Hekla the the
volcano in Iceland had blown and caused
bad weather yeah we learned about that
in Iceland that's what they claim they
like to claim responsibility for the
here we are and you know 2019 and the
Sheila Shaw is barricading at the gates
once again and the folks are rising up
for a good reason
what have you got in your little notes
there because we haven't actually
evolved since then because remember
during the French Revolution you made a
film about this with gold money calm and
about John law and the acid not because
a signet was basically a fiat currency
here in France that was backed by all
the property that they had seized from
the Catholic Church there's a derivative
it was a derivative and nowadays I
realized it dawned on me with all these
negative interest rates all of these
crazy economic policies emanating from
our governments but particular from the
central banks is because we actually do
have globally and a signet because most
people think that banks lend to
businesses and that's what they're doing
and everybody's looking at the ECB to
cut rate so they can lend to businesses
and grow the economy but actually over
85 percent of all bank lending is for
properties and property bubbles so we're
stuck with that right I mean that's a
transfer payment and they
is derivative they use modern channels
of banking and conduits to collateralize
the property in the modern Ising not of
course the French government at the time
simply seized via the Catholic Church
their property securitized it and sold
their currency back as such but here in
the 2019 era they did they do it using
reverse collateralized mortgage
obligations and fancy Wall Street
products but as you point out so so well
there this is a replay of all the
elements that led to the French
Revolution using financial engineering
and securitization and derivatives to
debase the currency and the currency is
being debased well you reach an endpoint
of how much the value of the property
can go up and with the acid not the
French people demanded they print more
of these Awesomenauts
so that the property prices can continue
to rise because they didn't want them to
go down so we have that global situation
right now it did it was able and
possible because we went off the gold
standard in 1971 at the same time it
wouldn't have worked without the fact
that the boomers hit the right age they
were entering the workforce at that time
and that was a massive population so you
could create a Ponzi sort of scheme
here's a headline to prove my theory
that what we're seeing right now is akin
to back at the S ignite and the collapse
of the astronaut and the strife that
followed the reign of terror that
happened here in France a banks are now
referring people to food bank to help
them pay their mortgage this is in
Australia so it's called food bank South
Australia has been approached by banks
to refer their clients to the charity in
the hope that it will prevent people
from defaulting on mortgage payments not
let them eat brioche but let them eat
food bank this is a real let them eat
cake moment another replay so we've got
a couple of almost verbatim replays of
the Revolutionary times of friends so
not only are they collateralizing
property as you point out it's
there's nothing reinvented here it's all
property backed and now instead of
letting them eat slices of brioche
they're allowing the folks to use their
foods to know they're subsidizing the
food banks thankful food so they don't
default on their mortgages these are
normal middle class upper middle class
and even indeed upper class people but
their stretch they have 10x they might
be earning a million other dollars a
bank to issue them food coupons so they
don't default on their mortgage they're
calling it vouchers these banks the bank
you have a mortgage with a bank the bank
is concerned that you are not able to
meet that mortgage because your income
has not gone up and the prices continue
to rise so they're creating vouchers
that they give to hurry up virtual
reality virtual Brea token as it were
and I see oh yes a brioche yes on the
ethereum blockchain it's an e rc 20
token and they're throwing it I see we
found a use case for a theory on client
so here again we we've had 10 years 20
years in Australia to feed this property
bubble there to keep that going because
if you're not working in the commodities
business in Australia then your your
property speculator and you have the a
signet so here's the unusual situation
Food Bank South Australia chief
executive Greg Pattinson told ABC radio
Adelaide it was still exploring how the
program would work quote that's what we
are exploring with some of the banks at
the moment and it hasn't started yet
because we are still working through the
process we've never been approached by
financial institutions in the past and
the banks to their credit are doing the
right thing and trying to find a way of
keeping people in their houses so now in
the medieval times you have the church
and they had a lot of property and here
you have the Church of central banks and
they're treated as Saints and apostles
they definitely are infallible banks
have been determined and deemed to be
infallible they are not punished by
anything there is no
mortal that can ever punish them because
this would cause sleepless nights and
our whole fabric of society and the
system around us would collapse should
we question yes like God God's too big
to fail so was essential this is what
they said at the time pre French
Revolution that they were infallible
these corrupt priests that were
wandering around Europe at that time you
know they were shaking down people for
indulgences and nevertheless here we
have another let them eat brioche moment
and I want to turn to another part of
this this trying to sustain this a
signal system that we have around the
world and you had predicted here on
Kaiser report that cutting interest
rates down to zero and then to negative
that it would cause deflation and here's
a headline from Bloomberg central bank's
negative interest rates were supposed to
increase spending stopped deflation and
stimulate the economy they may have done
the exact opposite so this is based on a
study from the University of Bath in
England and you had to wait 10 years
after Kaiser report told you this would
happen
and here they're saying yes they don't
credit us but we were right right so
Paul Krugman and Danny Blanchflower and
other economists and former central
bankers argued that this type of money
printing would create inflation however
what it did was it kept a zombie banks
alive and they pushed out companies that
could create actual jobs and innovation
and genuine taxable in inflation
economic activity and by catering to the
zombies the zombies got bigger and
bigger and as such became a black hole
of debt so the black hole looked at the
cheap rates and negative rates are
increasing that black hole of debt in
that's deflation and now negative
interest rates are soft default on
sovereign debt that's also the place but
again going back to my theory that this
is an acid not they were never ever
going to lend to businesses businesses
don't exist in this world where
financialized world what they ran out of
was greater fools back in the 1980s when
we began this bond market bubble when
interest rates were at 20% and now
they're down to zero and even negative
what we had always was a greater fool to
roll over your debt who could back in
the 80s you had to you know take out a
mortgage to two and a half times your
income you had to put 20% down then they
cut the that down to 3% down then to 0%
down and even they would pay you to take
a mortgage they would give you the
deposit essentially they would loan you
the deposit and add it to the mortgage
so you came up with that then you could
always roll it over and well because
interest rates are lower now than they
were in the 80s you could you don't need
to just borrow two and a half times your
income you could do five times and then
seven and then in central London it's 12
times your income so there's always been
a fool willing to say okay I'll take out
12 times my income what could go wrong
because I know in a few years time maybe
somebody will do it for 15 times but
that fool never came along to your point
so the lending has been to property and
property assets are collateralizing
ever-greater lending into ever grading
misallocated resources into inflated
property bubbles yes this is Iceland you
know Iceland the banks lent to the
property markets they used a collateral
to create this enormous bubble and then
a popped and the entire country went
bust this is being done on a global
scale what we saw in 2008 the world came
to a crashing stop Iceland went under
Ireland was faced with near extinction
there was this huge multi hundred
trillion dollar bailout and now we're at
the end game of that where the property
values that were inflated to these
incredible values where you've got the
guy at Citadel
hedge fund ken Griffith buying a flat in
New York for 280 million dollars right
so you know if shorted here's the
Titanic here's the world economy it's
the Titanic in 2008 it hit the iceberg
it started to sink and here's ken
Griffith with this 280 million dollar
flat it goes up in value okay when it
hits perpendicularity okay that's it
that's where right now
well we reached a shortage of fools
that's what's missing in the world we
need to grow more fools and
in fact in the United Kingdom when you
know there's a help to buy scheme and
remember George Osborne introduced that
in the UK his mom loves the program and
the fools that bought that are using it
love the program but other people like
Kai's report might suggest it was a
Ponzi scheme
we have the Signet and what are they
doing with the help to buy scheme six
years after we called it a Ponzi scheme
but the fact is the the government is
having to say well now you could take
out a 35-year mortgage because remember
that's how we had greater fools you had
less deposit down you extended the
mortgage through time and you lowered
interest rates so now we're at the
endgame we know what happened in France
maybe this could well if you look around
the world and you see the unrest that
it's the beginning of that sort of thing
when the asset not falls apart right
instead of having one revolution in
France or the Russian Revolution of the
American Revolution you have a global
insurrection against banker occupation
GI Bo right and they're all joining up
forces the G Li Shan will join forces
with the folks in Hong Kong when forces
and Arab nations and it's all the
awesome now essentially that's what they
owe us and on fiat currency Titanic
slash nightmare so we gotta go to the
second half
remember stay tuned welcome back to the
Kaiser report I'm Max Keiser time now to
turn to mark Vleck who publishes the
annual in gold we trust report we're
gonna get into this massive tome quickly
mark welcome all right great to have you
on now you're from Liechtenstein first
of all I'd like the way you say like
this time how do you say it
I'd say listener Stein isn't that sound
cool I feel like I'm in a crazy movie
something well we are in Paris you are
from Vienna
so you're Austrian in more ways than one
many of our guests here on Kies report
and watch the show call themselves a
part of the Austrian School of Economics
are you an Austrian School of Economics
person what does it mean to you
well I would say so I mean it's
quite important for our development it
has been very important the Austrian
School of Economics I think helps to
really see that there is actually an
alternative way to view the monetary
system so it's not only central banking
it doesn't have to be central banking
necessarily but like mainstream
economics just takes that as a given and
I think that's perhaps one of the
biggest advantages if one studies the
Austrian School of Economics just that
one really realizes ok there can be
another way and the central banking may
not be the Holy Grail right now you're a
big fan also of the Bitcoin standard
that book buy safety Nomos I am yes and
he goes into detail into his view of the
Austrian School of Economics and these
are real he really hates Kansans and and
their idea of printing money ad
infinitum and to that point there are
over seventeen trillion in negative
yielding bonds in Europe in what School
of Economics is this or do negative
yields defy the laws of time and space
and finance and in other words there's
all this is definitely not Austrian
school definitely not I think it's it's
basically a function of this debt based
monetary system which we have which
basically brings us to a point where we
have an ever-expanding amount of debt
and then we need central bankers to kind
of try to inflate the way out of this
and and we've landed at the point where
we're pretty much at the end of the road
in terms of yields in terror in terms of
interest rates and we really need to
order the central bankers have the urge
to really try to reflate the system in a
new kind of way and there's all kind of
interesting debates going around
currently which is quite interesting to
follow I think we are at the verge of
this new paradigm where this reflation
will really hit the new gear sooner or
later right let's talk about this a
little bit okay so inflating out of debt
so money is constantly created to pay
down the debt that you're creating and
you create more money to pay down
and there's this vicious cycle and if
you know we know because the Cantillon
effect if you're a friend of the banker
and you're the first in line to get that
fresh money you can make a lot of money
in buying assets you know you can buy a
chalet in Liechtenstein you can buy fine
art but if you are not part of that
group by the time the money gets down to
you you're paying more for groceries
you're paying more for gasoline so you
experience that price inflation and it
creates this enormous gap between the
haves and the have yachts and they have
knots right and so but this negative
rate seems like more of a default an
outright default on a bond then an
attempt to inflate one's way out of debt
I see you nodding your head what do you
think yeah I think one can make the
argument that it's kind of a soft
default I mean you you get you've 99
cents on the dollar back or even less if
you have a negative one percent yield so
that's basically a partial default sure
but I think the main intention is really
to push this currency out force it out
and and really I mean in Switzerland and
Liechtenstein where we we have the Swiss
franc we have pretty negative interest
rates already and this is a huge huge
problem obviously for asset managers for
for all these pools of funds they really
need to do something with with with
assets obviously they invested in
equities bonds less and less an
alternative corporate bonds less and
less an alternative and and once this
kind of parody it's the US dollar I
think really that's that's really an
interesting environment for gold and
Bitcoin you know it's almost like a
statutory financial crime being foisted
upon let's say pension fund managers who
are obligated by law to buy government
debt if that government debt is a
negative yielding debt it's a negative
interest rate debt they have no choice
they have to buy that debt even though
it means that they're bankrupting all
these pensions and so where do they get
away with this because the social
contract you know we're in Europe right
now we are in Paris we're in home of
really the whole idea of the social
contract and the idea of the
Enlightenment and if the social contract
is broken according to John Locke the
people must revolt you know and we're
seeing that we see the CLA zone we see
in Hong Kong we've seen Occupy Wall
Street we've seen this all over the
world what we call the global
insurrection against banker occupation
would you would you put it in those
terms I get to ask this question because
we are in Europe it's a bit of a
highfalutin question but however is it a
break in the actual social contract that
is girding society together I think so I
mean quite a few indications that this
kind of social contract in German it's
called gain a tot ziens fetterlock which
is also quite a quote an interesting
word is somewhat breaking down and
people are also losing kind of the trust
in in this social contract I think one
of these indications also would be like
dropping birth rates so people really
have to take care of themselves if they
want to live that kind of life with
which they were used to growing up and
they really don't know how to manage
that with like two or three kids even
that's why you've got birth rates
scratching at one actually in in in
Germany and even in in countries like
like France and and Spain which
traditionally had higher birth rates
these birth rates have been declining
during the last ten years especially so
so that's one of these indications
another indication I think is the whole
crypto phenomena which is obviously
embraced by the younger generation more
and and and they think perhaps okay
who knows if really this whole Fiat
system collapses down the road when I
when I'm at my pension age I may be able
to save myself from an economic point of
view if I have a few bitcoins right so
that's also I think a part of this
mistrust in the social contract right
well let's turn to this
massive report I've seen a lot of
reports in my day
but I've never seen a report like this
it's huge and I've been through it and
every single page has some good stuff in
it so incremental is the company anyone
could get this as a PDF yes so they can
contact I guess the name of the report
is gold in the age of a roading trust
the very thing we're talking about gold
is now on the upswing all of the
institutions the family as you just
mentioned banks things that are the
social contract these are all dissolving
in real time and this is now reflected
in the price of gold you publish this in
May and just two weeks ago Mark Carney
confirmed this trust is gone
globalization is over what next for what
people are familiar with and that is
fiat money fiat currency like the dollar
of the Euro etc I think one has to
differentiate very much where one lives
or which kind of culture one has in
terms of fiat currencies we I say we in
in in Central Europe for instance in
Switzerland again and an Austrian
Germany we were brought up with a
relatively stable money and relatively
stable purchasing power which is
declining now not perhaps in terms of
consumer price inflation but in terms of
a purchasing power of real estate so so
so people now starting to to question a
little bit this this the system also
from from the field money side if you
are on the other side living in South
America or living in the Middle East I
think you've got a completely different
view of fiat money you already were much
more skeptical so the eroding trust
which we termed this report also mainly
refers to I say Western societies which
still had generally the feeling that
this is a stable system but but this is
I think now also on its way down let's
talk about the ECB the European Central
Bank it's really mostly the old
Bundesbank right and it became
the European Central Bank it's German
German is the biggest economy in Europe
and this basically the Germany is
running the show and yet I remember a
few years ago when people were aghast at
the balance sheet expansion of the Fed
and they were saying well this will
never hit the ECB the Germans and
Germans would never allow this type of
monetary madness and yet they certainly
went ahead and did that and now the
results are pretty obvious I mean I
would think the German people would are
starting to get a bit nervous if not
quite upset about this so Germans
definitely are nations of savers
I mean also that is declining a little
bit but but still it is more in their
genes than in other countries and savers
in terms of saving in the bank account
and not investing so so they really get
a problem if they have negative interest
rates so they were kind of okay with
zero interest rates which they've been
living with for quite a few years
actually so that's in real terms
negative interest rates anyway but if
once you have nominally negative
interest rates then then people really I
think are not happy so so so that will
really be I think the point when when a
broader potentially brought a wave of
unhappiness regarding ECB will rise the
key word in all this course is trust
trust is the key word and you know in
crypto and in Bitcoin trust is a big
word because it's trustless Trust is
unneeded the transactions are self
verifying you don't need a third party
to apply that stamp of approval and in
this in this report gold and the age of
eroding trust you put Bitcoin right up
there with gold it's essentially gold
and bitcoin are together in your view of
how to play this collapsing a world of
collapsing trust is that correct yes I
think it's it's important to to not
neglect generally the technological
progress which is going on on the crypto
currency
site generally which is obviously also
being followed and tried to being taken
advantage of from central banks so so so
it's just important if we really want to
see the whole picture to to follow
what's going on but when it comes to
Bitcoin I mean this this discussion is
is always interesting what are the
advantages of Bitcoin versus gold gold
is obviously a physically metal it's an
internal metal it is just never dying
and bitcoin is a man-made system so so
that would be one fundamental difference
but then again from from it from a term
of hard money Bitcoin one can make the
argument is even harder money than gold
in the medium term so so it would be
really an interesting measure of value
so I think one needs to follow it
closely right we're in an interesting
camp of being both gold and Bitcoin
we're gonna talk about that some more in
another segment if you can hang on but
thanks for being on this episode of
Kaiser report
thank you well that's gonna do it for
this episode of the Kaiser report with
me max Kaiser and Stacey we'd like to
thank our guest mark of Alec incremental
this is the thing you got to get the PDF
it's free if you let's get in touch with
us it skies a report on Twitter or Mac
eyes report calm until next time bye Oh
[Music]